i really just worry about um you know
google being able to swing an election
at least when facebook rips the hunter
biden story off the internet two or
three weeks before the election which is
complete crap and they shouldn't be
allowed to do it
but when they did that people noticed
and you know you have the streisand
effect sort of thing where it's this
discussion right you can talk about it
and at least the censorship was
transparent but with google they can
change their search algorithms to you
know if they're subtle enough i think
you could change it a meaningful amount
suppress this information about trump
boost this information about biden
and all of a sudden
you know do you really live in a free
country anymore
all right we are in studio and joining
me today is the ceo of teal capital
the co-author of zero to one which i
keep on the set normally right over
there
and the next senator from the great
state of arizona blake masters
welcome to the reuben report thank you
it's great to be here i'm glad to have
you man i've wanted to do this for a
while we wanted to do it in person yes
uh as i said you are the co-author of
that book which i think was really one
of sort of formative things for me to
get involved in the tech
world and all of that and i know that's
obviously something that interests you a
lot so why don't we start
there how do you start working with teal
and getting some of these ideas across
about making new things yeah well i was
a student at stanford law school and i
remember my friend said hey peter thiel
you know the founder of paypal i was
going to teach a class and so we should
take that class and i didn't know that
much about peter then i knew it was
libertarian businessman you know
billionaire uh time to paypal that
seemed cool um good right so he was into
seasteading you know this idea that you
should maybe think about how to start
new countries
we should get back we'll talk about that
actually so he seemed like a cool guy
and uh you know what an opportunity to
take a class from someone who wasn't
just a professor you know i actually
done something in the world so i took uh
he i took that class and sort of
befriended peter this was my second year
in law school i went to go intern for
him at his venture capital fund
that summer and then he came back taught
another class my last year in law school
i took really good notes on that class i
just basically typed down everything he
said
because i liked the first class but i
can't tell you too much about it because
it's all lost to memory right i wasn't
like a big note taker in college because
who cares um but the second time i was
prepared so i wrote down everything
peter said cleaned it up posted it
online
and these notes became kind of like a
phenomenon in silicon valley this was
like 2012. because i think it was the
first time
you could actually kind of collect all
of peter's thoughts on building a
startup that's what the class was about
startups and technology companies and
how to do new things in a stagnant
society and so i think people who are
interested in peter at the time
and his stock was sort of rising like
facebook was just about to ipo um you
could piece together things from like
interviews print interviews youtube but
there was no one set of like here's
peter thiel's thoughts on how to start a
startup all of a sudden me as this
random stanford student was publishing
this online and so silicon valley a
couple thousand people just started
following week over week uh these notes
and became this really successful so you
were doing it in real time i was doing
the class putting the notes up and
people were following so basically they
were getting the education for free
that's right alongside which is really
interesting because it was this awesome
class and you know i think we ultimately
turned it into a very successful book
but i think it would have just died like
all the material and like you know peter
worked hard to to organize all the
thinking for the class
but uh if it's not recorded if it
doesn't you know actually get outside
the classroom it just dies there and
that would have been a big shame yeah so
the the basic premise of the book is
that the next facebook is not going to
be facebook to go from zero to one you
have to do something fully new right
does that feel more
sort of relevant now than it did even
you know eight ten years ago because of
the sort of upheaval and weird spot that
we're in right now it does i think we
desperately do need new technology to
sort of take things to the next level we
have a remarkably stagnant society um i
think people get distracted like the
iphone 13 pro just came out it's like
congratulations the camera is much
better and that's cool wait it's a half
inch bigger or bigger
bigger better it's good enough we
literally just shot a campaign ad in
cinema mode on iphone 13 pro and it's
like holy [ __ ] this is actually a really
good camera so there's some innovation
but it's also marginal and this is all
confined to sort of your smartphone or
sort of i.t broadly or software startups
um actually society looks so much like
it did in the 1970s like we're not
moving faster in some ways we're moving
slower you know we don't build houses
any better or more efficiently now
actually housing prices are just going
through the roof right so so much in our
society is stagnant and zero to one is
yeah narrowly a business book but
broadly it's the sort of exploration of
why
is so much uh of our society just
stagnant like why can't we do new things
is that kind of the core of why you want
to go into politics or is it fair to say
you even want to go into politics in a
way or you're being sort of dragged to
politics i sense that with a lot of
people that are getting involved it was
like i didn't really want to be a
politician at first but somebody's got
to fix this somebody's going to have
somebody i definitely have that that
view of it um i mean
i'm getting into it i really want to get
into it i think it's important you know
i'm i'm loving campaigning i want i'm
going to win the race so i just told
everybody here you just told everyone so
that's going to happen yeah you're right
but it'd be it'd be nice in some sense
like if i didn't have to like if things
were working if we didn't have this
establishment that uh that was presiding
over i think this cultural and and uh
economic decay then i wouldn't have to
but that's not where we are and i have
to and i think we need some new thinking
in government so it's also
the most important thing i could be
doing i didn't think this was the case
in like 2012 when i was taking those
notes i thought
you know i saw mitt romney lose to
barack obama and it's like how could
this possibly happen i thought the first
obama term was so bad that of course
like a successful businessman governor
uh mitt romney you know he even looks
the part yeah of course he's gonna win
he definitely looks and then it was just
i think it was too nice and
just
sort of failed to understand this was a
fight for the future of the country and
he lost and to me
uh i've always been political but
sort of like well if the if the right if
conservatives if republicans just aren't
going to be serious about winning um
maybe it's just the controlled
opposition and we're just going to have
a managed decline politically and that's
why i wanted to go into business it's
like i could actually do something
you know you could start and invest in
startups and if we can get technology to
work sort of faster than government can
[ __ ] progress then maybe we can have a
good future
so
you know i basically thought it was all
over honestly until 2016 and trump comes
on the scene and sort of busts up the
establishment and whatever your view of
that is like he did it i think it's
great i thought the administration was
very successful but he showed me that
new things are possible in politics
and i think we need much more of a
startup mentality because we have too
much stagnation too much bureaucracy um
we're really drowning in it yeah so it's
just time for i never i've never thought
about this way but would you consider
trump in 2016 is sort of a zero to one
moment totally impossible absolutely
yeah
absolutely um he came i thought it was
it was sort of refreshing it was really
honest i mean i think this is why he was
elected he was like the one person
telling the truth which is this left
establishment and the right
establishment uh it doesn't work like
people you know he he it was the emperor
has no clothes where he's just like you
you you you're getting screwed you're
getting ripped off china's eating our
lunch you know and he'd been remarkably
consistent about that decade over a
decade
and uh i think people
that that resonated with them like the
election that we deserved in 2016 was
trump versus bernie sanders which of
course the dnc wouldn't let happen and
they rigged it so the bernie couldn't
win but um and i disagree with bernie
sanders on everything i think he's just
wrong like that left-wing sort of
communist politics like that doesn't
work but bernie was at least more honest
than hillary cause he came on the scene
and said like this is this is rigged
this isn't a this is establishment is
failing people and that's what trump's
message was too they just had very
different uh policy prescriptions and i
think trumps were much better do you
kind of admire the sort of evilness of
the dnc in a way like that they rigged
it against bernie and admirers and
admirer is too strong well admire the
way i always respect it and
sort of well admire like the way the
doctor admired the alien in the first
alien movie you know it was so merciless
that it was killing everything and it
had no remorse look
the the left is serious about power and
they know how to play the game and again
that's there's something horrible about
that but
they play to win and so
often republicans don't play to win we
play to be mr nice guy and then try to
get some cinecure at some think tank you
know when we lose
and i think people are just sick of that
because our backs against the wall
there's no more room to play defense
what do you do about the nice guy part
because i heard you speak a couple weeks
ago here in l.a and my general takeaway
i know you a little bit through twitter
mostly but my takeaway was oh he's a
nice guy like do you think that can
actually work in this bro like that we
need these sort of corrupt mean people
willing to do horrible [ __ ] to become
politicians well i think you got to play
to win and i'm definitely playing to win
so i think i present like a reasonable
person i think i am you know nice person
or whatever but uh but i care more about
doing the right thing than being nice
and so i'm sure at some point in the
campaign like i want to run a positive
campaign i think that's how i break
through by showing people in arizona how
i'm different but uh i'm sure the fangs
come out you know i can i can be sharp
elbowed and i think you have to be i
have super thick skin
um i don't think it's about being mean
for the sake of it but i do think we
have to understand like right now we're
playing for the future of the country
and i think if the left wins uh we we
won't have a good country we won't even
have a country in 30 years necessarily
so i think the stakes are really high
and i'm willing to do what it takes to
uh to win and shore it up so that we can
have a successful future i don't think
that means be brash and be rude um but i
do think it means republicans have to
get serious about like acquiring and
using power to sort of build the society
that works brash and rude comes when you
run for president there you go it's one
thing it's just it's just senate now if
you had to really just sort of sum up
your political positions it strikes me
as some sort of blend between like a
traditional conservative with
libertarian leaning something like that
is that kind of fair to say yeah my um
you know i've i've been i've been there
to libertarianism it's like i grew up
with iron brand and milton friedman on
the bookshelf in college i got super
into the austrian school you know von
mises and total free market economics
and uh i think it's very important to
understand i think it's good to be
coming from that place um i also think
we need to update so it's like i'm a
very pro-market guy very pro-business
guy um but like there is no free trade
with china you know and so if you have
these free trade people negotiating
trade agreements agreements with china
there's a sense in which you just you
just lose because china doesn't have
free trade like they're always the way
that society works right ccp is just
subsidizing domestic industries they can
dump steel uh it's just not a level
playing field and so we you know for
decades it's just we have free traders
at the negotiating table and and you
know the worse they are at negotiating
the better they think they've done
right it's free trade we can't possibly
put a tariff on china and it's like no
we just we we took all this productive
industrial capacity and we just shipped
it to southeast asia to save a buck you
know and in theory that's economically
efficient in practice it hollows out
your your sort of middle american
economy to the great detriment of most
americans and so i think generally like
a pro-market guy laissez-faire as much
as possible internally but like you've
got to pay attention to your trade
relationship with china and i think for
the longest time republicans and
democrats botched it and president trump
came on you know and again emperor has
no closed moment he's just like what are
you guys doing this is stupid they're
eating your lunch yeah and that was true
and yet he's not president anymore he's
not present anymore um which is a big
shame but like his policies were working
you know wages in this country stagnated
from 1970 or at least the early 70s all
the way until 2016 and they finally
started going up median wages finally
started going up under president trump
and he basically gets no credit for that
and now all those gains are reversed
because biden and harris are just
reversing the policies so i think
there's room to be like a super pro
market republican but also understand
that markets are supposed to be tools
for human flourishing like the goal is a
successful productive society right the
goal is not some abstract economic ideal
is is that what conservatives have sort
of forgotten how to argue for i get the
libertarian stuff for sure but they've
sort of traded in that oh there's a
greater good here that we should all be
trying to attain and that sort of
disappeared that's right and that's why
i think um you know on the right you
have big business interests that are
super pro open borders right because
they just care about cheap labor right
and there's a way you can rationalize
that with gdp or sort of economic
efficiency arguments but they don't look
at the consequences to society you know
or
in my announcement video i had a
controversial line it was amazing that
it was even controversial i would have
thought it was common sense but i said
you ought to be able to raise a family
in america on one single income
which doesn't that mean you hate women
or something that's what the democrats
said they attacked me for being sexist
it's like i didn't say anything sexist
at all it's like you used to be able to
raise a family on one income in this
country something happened globalization
happened maybe it's a complicated story
to tell
but but you can't do it anymore and i
think that's a problem and maybe you
know a husband and wife uh maybe the
wife wants to go to work and the husband
wants to stay at home and raise the kids
i generally think it's good if someone
stays at home and raises the kids or
maybe you want to have two two people
you know
work and that's fine that should be a
choice you should be able to afford to
raise a family you know so
i didn't say you couldn't choose i just
said wouldn't it be nice if we were more
prosperous but that's not the way so
many uh even people on the right
have come to think it's more like well
think about all the gdp if we send the
husband to work and you send the wife to
work or husband and husband whatever you
send two workers and then you've got to
get the nanny and now you've got three
incomes and look at all this gdp that
we're creating you know well it's like
what if what if that's not as good for
the kids
wouldn't it be nice to have the choice
but apparently not
apparently not so what do you think is
really crazy what do we call this new
thing like is this what populism like
the new populism right is like what what
is it sort of because i think when you
say gender not you specifically but when
people say even if now i say i don't
mind if people call me a conservative
now i would say i'm sort of like a
future conservative or something like
that
but when you say conservative to like a
20 year old they freak out like i don't
know like it doesn't say that there's a
branding problem yeah what do you do
about that i don't think populist is
necessarily the right label like i don't
mind if people call me that i don't call
myself that um i do i do think what i'm
saying when i'm espousing are
conservative messages i consider myself
conservative but uh obviously you can't
keep everything the same society moves
on and so it's about sort of this uh you
gotta be a little bit wise about it like
what's worked in the past what's good
about what we've inherited from our uh
ancestors and i think there's a whole
lot right the left wants to throw
everything out um in about the past
because it's not perfect right now so
everything in the past must be
irredeemable and evil right that's a
mistake we got to take so much of what
we've inherited and just think about how
to conserve it in the future while also
adapting
to new things so i i think it's
conservative but it's not like ostrich
bury your head in the sand and just
repeat whatever ronald reagan was saying
right and i think conservatives need to
update so whether you want i think it's
just a new republican party that we're
building you know paul ryanism doesn't
work right i think reagan did what he
had to do in the 80s and um
people have basically just been trying
to copy him ever since but if this is
just the point zero to one if you just
look at facebook you look at ronald
reagan you look at what worked in the
past and if you just mindlessly copy it
decade over decade you'll get to a point
where that thing doesn't even work
anymore except you haven't invested the
time or the energy and thinking about
like what you should be saying now and
we're going to talk a little more about
big tech in a bit but like are you
worried that even if all the ideas are
right and and decent and you know pretty
much most people can get on board that
between the media and big tech and
everything else that they just won't let
those ideas be heard in a way that the
average person could get across i mean
you know i was out there on the campaign
trail with larry elder and it was like
this guy was saying a lot of what you
just said there right and he's a very
decent man and the pedigree that he has
and everything else and the media
treated him horribly i mean the black
face of white supremacy
uh i do worry about that although i
think california's just gone
to a first approximation yeah and thanks
for coming by the way thank you thanks
for being here it's good to visit
california
also good to get back home yeah uh
arizona's not not there yet and i think
you know the country's not there yet i
think if arizona goes the way of
california if the country goes the way
of california it's all over um it's just
a one-party state it's dysfunctional
yeah you can't get a fair hearing but
these ideas are popular it's basically
like you should be pro business and pro
market but make sure that that's
actually working for the working class
and middle class like most people in
america agree with me that in this
country you should be able to raise a
family on one single income like the
criticism of that statement is that it's
banal because i haven't said how i'm
gonna do that it's more just like blake
you're just saying it's good to be
prosperous or something but people
shouldn't be picking uh fights with it
because it's sexist or because it's
impossible like that's just giving up
and so you know it's
another thing i'm talking about on the
campaign trail is just education
and there's a partisan way to talk about
this where i think the the left-wing
ideology 1619 project and critical race
theory all that stuff is horrible but
even if you wipe that stuff away if we
got rid of it tomorrow that'd be great
and it would also not fix our schools
right because our schools have been
failing for decades it's like you
graduate kids that can't even read or
write because we just lower the
standards and we fail to teach the
basics and so i think when you point
this stuff out it's not even that
ideological it's just so many things
about our society don't work
and we just need new leadership that is
uh is going to privilege competence and
execution
over anything else how do you think you
also show people that politics is in
everything that politics is in god and
the meaning of life and everything else
because that's what it's become to so
many people right so to say hey i'm not
gonna solve all of your problems we're
gonna try to make things better we're
gonna try to as you said take the good
stuff bring in some new stuff but like
we can't solve every single thing part
of is getting out there with that exact
message and reminding people that
because um you know thinking about like
my cohort i'm a millennial and thinking
about generation z below me
these kids are so attracted to the
left-wing
totalitarian message the aoc stuff right
the progressive ideology and that's a
totalizing ideology it does purport to
solve all your problems it's just like
just believe in the party line and give
the state unlimited power and we'll take
care of everybody cradle to grave in a
literal sense right um but then also
the the woke-ism the progressivism it is
a substitute religion you know i've come
to believe it's basically a militant
form of christianity uh sort of devoid
of all the the
redemption and you know the benefit
and so
it is a whole totalizing philosophy but
i think that's really scary and i think
if you remind people like hey this is
where that goes when you follow that
path you know we have so many historical
examples and you just um
you remind people like that's not the
job of government like you're supposed
the government's job is to create
conditions so that people can flourish
and protect people's rights so that
people can figure out the meaning of
life on their own you know i do think we
need a sort of re-christianization i do
think a religious revival in america
would be very good it's not my job to
make that happen but what you're seeing
with the woke takeover of everything is
something very very much like that um i
just think it's so crazy 60 or 70
percent of people in this country won't
go for it if we have messengers who can
say like this is horrible do you see
this thing do everything that you
described there do you see that as sort
of the what i would say is at this point
the obvious end of sort of purely
secular liberalism that at the end of
just i believe only in what's here and
now you're going to get all of this
crazy hysteria around government because
because people need to believe one way
or another they can say they don't
believe but they believe yep no we have
a religious impulse and when the left
doesn't think they believe in god or
christianity this is what we get
and i think that's really warped i think
it's bad i think it is hurting a lot of
people and i think it'll hurt a lot more
um
it's it's a it's a militant sort of
secular religion they think they're
atheist but actually it's just
it's really devastating it's just
shifted it's just shifted you mentioned
potentially a husband and husband it
seems to me that the republicans have
pretty much all moved on gay marriage do
you see any issue there when when you're
talking about some of the religious
stuff or even maybe some of the base
that still isn't quite there i don't see
it but i'm in super super republican
activist rooms every day in arizona and
i just don't hear that at all you know
my hometown congressman in tucson i was
growing up jim colby i think was the
first openly gay member of congress if
not he was an early one but uh when he
spoke at the 2000 convention
in favor of george w bush um his
nomination
i remember the texas delegation actually
turned their back on jim colby when he
was speaking right that's sort of where
the country was or that's where texas
was in 2000 and then in 2016 right fast
forward 16 years later
i'm there in cleveland at the rnc
convention with peter and peter gave
this speech and he had this line where
he said i'm proud to be gay yeah i'm
proud to be a republican but most of all
right applause line i am proud to be an
american and the crowd went down the
crowd went nuts you know and and uh the
trump kids were sitting in a sort of
private vip box there and they all stood
up and applauded right it was just
to me that was a bookend i was i was
watching that on tv and it was before i
had ever met peter and i was still a
lefty at the time and i remember
thinking whoa something just happened
right just now like when they all
exploded but of course the next day the
media doesn't right they don't do
anything like that right yeah
occasionally if anything he's somehow a
sellout for doing it or something like
that yeah right yeah i know i think
people have moved beyond this um i think
there's a sort of personal libertarian
streak in the at least in arizona right
republicans don't care um they don't
care what you do they don't care about
your family but you know but they don't
want to feel
uh
they don't want to feel like they're a
bigot or something because you know
because they're not on board with um
great questions
exactly about that exactly right and so
some people say like
gosh where does it stop right every
fortune 500 company seems to have these
political messages you know pro-lgbt
messages and if you believe what most
americans believe three years ago you're
you know racist and you're bigot and
you're retrograde people don't want that
they don't want to be bludgeoned over
the head with some agenda um but i think
most people are like pretty live and let
live
and i think it's positive development
for the country so i hear basically none
of none of this yeah i'm with you i just
felt it was worth asking because i do
see some little tension on some of the
stuff going on with the right there's
this sort of like catholic revival in
the midst of this where they're sort of
against it and it's like how do you
blend that with the libertarian part
sure but that's the real problem it has
to deal with stuff it's like the real
problem with marriage gay or straight is
that people just get divorced right
people don't get married you wait longer
and longer and people aren't forming
families and then when they do they fall
apart you know because i think every
force in society basically conspires
against young people
coupling and that's really bad but i
don't think that's a gay straight issue
i think everybody's divorce rates are
too high for everyone yeah you mentioned
you mentioned you're a millennial how
old are you 35 35 so i'm 45 i'm gen x
gen x
well then you already answered the
question do you feel like because i feel
this way the gen x basically got
completely passed over somehow totally
the boomers are still hanging on
let go of their power yeah they just
won't let go and they they i mean biden
and nancy pelosi and chuck schumer and
even trump i mean we've got all these
people in their late 70s into 80s still
running the show it should be the 45
year olds right now in the prime of
things and yet maybe we're just going to
be skipped over and it'll be you young
bucks at 35. you definitely get screwed
yeah uh i agree pelosi and schumer
should relinquish their power
immediately i like trump i hope he runs
again but yeah but he's the he's the one
i would want to see who's you know uh in
that generation run right well i don't
think you're bad because of your age
obviously but
we need a changing of the guard yeah i
mean we really just do i think the
median age of the us senate is 63. which
is pretty crazy because it's the median
rights there's a lot of senators that
are
70 80. dianne feinstein's like 127.
you know and it's actually i just kind
of feel bad for her like it's not clear
she knows where she is yeah the biden
thing you know i mean people make fun of
it and okay fine fair enough it's rough
and tumble in politics but it's actually
really sad
i think it's really sad i think it's
crazy um that we have a president that
clearly doesn't have a grip on things
like he's just not there that's not even
ideological criticism he's just not
fully able to do the job do you think if
it was trump they maybe would be talking
about that would that be such a bold
crazy statement i wonder if the media
would have something to say about that
he once drank with a cup remember the
glass with two hands that way it's a
biological disorder just gas lighting
yeah it's just gaslighting they want to
put they think people are stupid they
think we can't actually see that
president cannot string a sentence
together and this is really crazy um one
thing that's interesting though i have
not heard on the campaign trail oh blake
you're too young to be a u.s senator
and i'm sort of bracing myself for that
line of criticism you know because i do
have 20 years or 30 years even on some
of my competitors
but people do not feel this way actually
you know two-thirds of the republican
primary electorate in arizona is over 55
so it's not particularly young
electorate
but those people love me
it's you know because like how radical
is it to actually see a young
conservative who's been paying attention
who knows history who knows about the
good things in the past who knows how
important it is to carry this forward
but also is young and has the energy and
you can you know i got a lot of skin in
the game hopefully i have a long runway
left and i have young kids and i really
care about the country they're growing
up in and i think so many of the baby
boomer politicians you know my
competition in the primary
they're fine you know whatever but
there's a business guy and a military
guy and a politician
and it's just you have the career and
then you finish the career and it's like
well retirement sucks it's boring
and you don't want to think about
mortality and so you're just looking for
that capstone and so you have all the
cliche stuff like i'm just ready to go
back and serve my community you know and
it's like
no man i'm fighting for the the future
of this country so how much of
everything sort of that feels wrong with
the country right now is that it's that
tension between things that are
collapsing that aren't working anymore
even media you know like watching cnn
that now we can expose their lives every
two seconds online which we couldn't do
10 years ago and then their lives seem
to get more brazen that it's a tension
between like the the mainstream media
and the internet culture a tension
between young and old like we're just at
this weird turning point right now right
i think it's just stagnation and
ultimately it doesn't work and the
people who have been in charge of it and
presided over it won't admit that you
know um
does that does that give you hope that
as right now it feels where it's getting
out of control that it maybe is at its
depth at the end
it does it's weird because it's
simultaneously a very pessimistic
message like i'm up on the campaign
trail every night telling people like
it's really bad like my competition is
like our best days are right around the
corner and it's like i think that sounds
fake to people i hope our best days are
in the future and i am excited and
optimistic and that's why i'm running
because i think we can arrest the
decline and reverse it and have a good
country
going forward but um but it's really
bleak i think it's really bleak i think
things have not been working for so long
uh you know i think fiscal crises loom
you know we're just printing tons of
money seeing inflation it's just not
going to work this whole monetary policy
that we have the system itself i don't
know whether it has two years or 20
years but i don't think it has 50 years
right wait are you trying to tell me
that 3.5 trillion doesn't equal zero
because i have a calculator what is that
i was told it's like in the past
democrats who wanted to spend a lot of
money would have been honest enough to
say like this is expensive we had it's
an investment in ourselves right i mean
this goes back to the founding father
alexander hamilton was like you know
public debt we owe it to ourselves like
sometimes you gotta invest in
improvements um there's a fair debate to
have if
if you acknowledge the sort of stakes of
the debate like if you have to spend 3.5
trillion make the argument
but again they think people are stupid
and they think they can come and say two
plus two is four 3.5 trillion equals
zero it's free my build back better
agenda is free it costs nothing it's
paid for and it's like what the hell is
that if you buy a two million dollar
house because you have two million
dollars like your house isn't free
it's
cost two million dollars and that's the
burrito example i used with this guy the
other day if you're at chipotle
and you order a burrito and they're like
it's 10 bucks and then you just punch
the guy behind you and take his 10 bucks
it still costs 10 bucks yeah that's free
it's free so it's crazy i don't know but
and i guess this stuff works over time i
mean they know what they're doing this
is a calculated uh
sort of linguistic manipulation but do
you think it's because they think they
can get away with it like they think the
media well because they do the media
then just repeats it as if it's true
they do yeah but i think the media
stranglehold is just weaker than it's
ever been yeah right and and i gave
president trump huge credit for this i
think the mainstream media was you know
garbage
frankly before 2016.
peddling the same sort of fake you know
bipartisan
center-left narrative
but i think trump came along and
totally just picked a fight with him it
was crazy and chaotic and all that but
he delegitimated the mainstream media
and so we live in this sort of
information environment that's
kind of wild it's hard to know who's
telling the truth it's hard to know who
to trust and then even if someone is uh
trustworthy they might be wrong about
some deeds so so people have to do the
work
and uh read a lot of things like covid
it's like how do how do you actually
know what's happening right is it the
hugest problem in the world i suspect
not anymore is it uh is it
sort of serious and we should pay
attention to these things um or is it
completely fake and
you know it's it's hard to actually know
like literally how many people are dying
of covid and at this point the problem
is experts the expert class has totally
de-legitimated itself and so if you
can't listen to experts
who can you listen to right and so i
think people don't know what to believe
there's a version of this about like
election integrity in arizona right we
just have this audit come out and it's
fascinating for me because i'm
campaigning i'm in these republican
activist rooms and before the audit came
out at least
i'd be talking to people who were just
sure
that dominion voting systems switch you
know whatever it is 300 000 votes for
trump
switched him to biden and it was simply
rigged or something
and
i'm you know that's not my view i do
think the election was unfair and stolen
in some sense um i think you can point
to like tremendous amounts of
irregularities and i think on the margin
certainly democrats cheat and steal and
in arizona there's a ballot harvesting
problem it's technically illegal but
goes unpoliced but i never really
thought and i think the audit shows this
that it it wasn't as simple as you know
cartoonish rigging of 300 000 votes um
but i'm i'm just so sympathetic to
people who do think that
because they know
you know the media would be happy to lie
to them
almost every journalist would lie to to
hurt president trump in some sense
election experts say you know studies
show that people know that this
narrative is so massaged and so fake and
so i think
when people can't trust the institutions
anymore when they can't trust the
experts they will latch on to whatever
sort of
emotionally uh feels right you would
agree in terms of a great twitter thread
on this because you were talking about
this and then you referenced i think it
was that atlantic it was atlantic the
article where they said it was they were
fortifying the election
so that you know they basically say a
cabal of people figured out how to
fortify the election and it's like then
the average person reads that and even
if you don't have the numbers right in
front of you to go oh they cheated this
way specifically it's kind of like if
you thought that hitler was you know
going to be re-elected you might cheat
right like you might
they spent years saying that president
trump was evil incarnate right in 2019
as late as 2019 nancy pelosi said he was
a illegitimate president um you know
only
elected because russia put him you know
this crazy [ __ ] that was really crazy
yeah hillary still got to tweet up he's
a legitimate president really crazy
stuff and then we actually have tons of
irregularities you actually do have this
sort of i think center left left wing
media ngo
corporate um
fusion of power that gets together and
says like how do we get trump out like
we know this happened we know they had
motive and opportunity like we know that
they were trying everything and then
they brag about it in time magazine we
just had to make sure that democracy
achieved the right result i mean it's
really sinister it's really orwellian
and so when you see all this that's why
i'm just so sympathetic to people who
who believe you know even the wildest
things about the election no
it wasn't fair i think trump wins in a
fair fight it's like pfizer knew that
they had received or were about to
receive emergency approval for the
vaccine before the election
but then we didn't find out about it
until after the election and their
official narrative on this is well we
didn't want to influence the election
and it's like trump's warp speed was a
huge development in 2020 like we created
the vaccine so quickly
and
maybe a lot of people might want to have
known about that before casting their
vote and pfizer just decided not to
release that info so in what sense is
that fair
how do you decide how much you can talk
about this stuff like whether your base
really wants you to talk about it
because obviously arizona just went
through the audit versus mainstream like
when the audit came out i i actually
didn't even send a tweet about it
because i was like it's hard to
understand what happened here i was just
like it's a headache yep because i'm
going to get an endless amount of hate
and maybe be demonetized or my video
will be deleted or whatever so how do
you balance between sort of maybe what
some of the base wants
how you feel about things and then what
will be accepted i mean it all kind of
sucks but you're a politician now yeah
but the best way to do it i think is to
not over calculate you know like i
people some some people criticize me um
i had a big twitter thread before the
audit and i said like remember before
the the friday where the audit results
came out i said regardless of what
happens like we're going to learn
something tomorrow um but regardless
let's remember the election was sort of
unfair and deeply troubled deeply
problematic in all these different ways
and i cataloged them because i wanted
that out
in the record then the audit comes out
friday and i didn't tweet about it until
saturday because i actually wanted to
read the report
and see what happens right instead of
just immediately latch on because
there's a lot there
and
people criticize me for that but it's
like i wasn't going to have the
consultant approved you know pre-planned
tweet just ready to go and beat up on
political enemies i wanted to see what
it said um and so i read it so
the the best way i know how to campaign
right and it's my first time but i think
people are ready for like authenticity
like i never say anything that i don't
think is true
i will go into these republican activist
rooms and they may not um
like what i'm saying but they will see
that like i'm telling them the truth as
i see it and that's the best i can do
and it's tough because sometimes these
you know people want you to pair it back
exactly what they say and if you don't
then you're a rhino or something like
that but then i just say like hey man
i'm obviously like with you right i'm a
very conservative person sort of limber
libertarian individualist techno you
know
i'm different than conservatives you've
seen before but
i'm obviously with you i'm just i see it
from a different perspective
i know the feeling man i know and that's
but i think people like that yeah
you can't i don't think you can survive
as a politician if you're just in this
room saying what they want to hear and
then you go to a different room you say
what they want to hear obviously you
talk to different groups somewhat
differently based on their interests
but all i can do is tell the truth as i
see it and
just go and share that message with
people right and that goes to the
tension of the internet now exposing a
lot of stuff in the old days you could
do that you could go to one room say one
thing it's completely fake and i think
we trained a whole generation of fake
politicians on the internet i think is
kind of a crazy place but it's healthy
in this respect i think it exposes who's
for real and who's not and i think you
know it's like remember the elizabeth
warren um drink a beer and i'm gonna get
me a beer
and then she you know her husband is
like come over here
and then trump was savage on that he was
so good right he's like
the husband's supposed to be there
what's happening right he's just like
and you know there were like 50 people
in that room yeah consultants and media
people and i'm gonna get me a beer i'm
gonna get my gosh you know and it's like
i kept saying it throughout the campaign
how can this billionaire hair plugged
orange man be more authentic than all of
these people
and he is he he absolutely is so all
right we're shifting a little bit to the
internet stuff so i want to talk about
the big tech thing you've been very
big on the big tech thing and what do we
do this is the perfect blend of like
okay libertarian principles free market
all of that but society seems to be
crumbling under algorithms
what do we do
we gotta reign in big tech we just have
to i think five years ago you know
people weren't ready for this um the big
tech companies actually were less
abusive five years they've grown a lot
like things have changed and this is
what i mean you need people in
leadership uh people in office who are
tracking these changes and who can
intervene
i think i'm a pro market guy you know
peter invested in facebook that's
fantastic we want companies that we
invest in to become huge and successful
but at a certain point when companies
become more powerful than most
governments
when a handful of corporations come to
dominate and control the flow of
information in society i think we can
afford to treat them differently
than you might treat a bakery or a hair
salon
and so i really just worry about
you know google being able to swing an
election
at least when facebook rips the hunter
biden story off the internet two or
three weeks before the election which is
complete crap and they shouldn't be
allowed to do it
but when they did that people noticed
and you know you have the streisand
effect sort of thing where it's this
discussion we can talk about it and at
least the censorship was transparent but
with google they can change their search
algorithms to you know if they're subtle
enough i think you could change it a
meaningful amount suppress this
information about trump boost this
information about biden
and all of a sudden
you know do you really live in a free
country anymore
and so i think we um i think we have to
pay attention to this conservatives
focus a lot on censorship and i think we
should because conservatives really are
censored they ripped president trump off
facebook and twitter while he was
president yeah meanwhile taliban
commanders you know have blue check
marks yeah so this is crazy and
censorship is a huge problem and i think
you know you can repeal section 230 and
you can treat the the platforms as
common carriers which i think we should
do
but i think the problems with big tech
are a lot deeper
too i worry a lot about like targeted
advertising
you know you just saw um the study that
came out last week that showed how bad
instagram is
for teenagers yeah especially teenage
women like they're mentioning it's like
a surprise surprise everyone's
pretending they're shocked oh my god i
can't we knew this right you knew this
yeah and it's just the endless feed and
then you hoover up all this data about
people and use it in pretty predatory
ways um sort of subterranean you're
hacking their psychology like these
companies employ psychologists on staff
as well as software designers to get
people hooked on the products to get
ever more data to serve them ever more
targeted ads and
i think we shouldn't be doing that at
least for teenagers like we shouldn't be
allowing facebook to advertise to kids
right now in some ways
like i know we can do things and let's
say you get into the senate we have the
hearings and everyone's seen the
hearings and even guys that i like at
the hearings those are ted cruz
but they're brutal no matter what
because even when there's a nice moment
when rand paul really you know gets
jacket twitter or ted cruz does you know
really gets somebody caught in a lie
nothing ever changes so is it possible
that we've now been manipulated
this is sort of my like matrix version
of this we've been manipulated in so
many ways now for for enough years that
no matter what you could do as part of
the government it would be like yeah you
know dropping a barrel i agree that's a
risk but i think that's uh to just
conclude that is to give up
and so i don't i think there's at least
still a really good chance you can do a
lot um
maybe not to start you know one senator
can't really unilaterally pass a bill
right but i think uh
i'm gonna get in there and make so much
noise and actually run effective
hearings and like i think i really do
know what to do with these companies
like josh hawley senator hawley's shown
a lot of leadership on this and if you
get a core group five or six people like
that you get the ball rolling it may
take some time but i think we actually
can make meaningful progress here
because i think also big tech is just
gonna get bigger and bigger right these
structural monopolies they just become
uh ever more profitable like unless we
rein them in they're just to take over
more and more ground
especially now that like they're not
even private companies right like
facebook is working with the biden
administration to decide what is coveted
misinformation jen saki says facebook
pulled us off and facebook you know like
a good boy pulls it off yeah and that's
really great things for facebook that's
why
facebook yeah of course they're a
private company they can make their own
decisions of course we have a giant ftc
you know under linocon right uh that
we're that we're going to use as a giant
threat to make you comply
i think this stuff is really dangerous i
don't think we can afford to give up
you know possibly these companies are
too big and powerful possibly they'll
just do everything they can to make sure
that people like me don't get elected um
but it's a risk we have to take yeah
because otherwise we're throwing in the
towel when i heard you speak a couple
weeks ago uh somebody asked you
something about this and basically you
that was your answer and then you said
at the end like you were like well what
are they gonna do kill me and everyone
kind of got quiet for a second but it's
like
yeah but it's like who knows what these
people could what they could do i'm not
saying they're coming to kill you but
like just the way they can manipulate
and make everybody hate everybody and
again after what i saw what they did to
larry elder and when i would google his
name after i'd be at rallies where there
was so much love so much support and
every single article in google it was
like i think 12 out of the 15 on the
first page hit piece hit piece hit piece
hit piece right and it's like that's a
it's a form it's like a digital
assassination right yeah no i mean i
think it'll get really ugly i do
but i think and you know i think social
media is really flawed like maybe the
world isn't instantly
uh shouldn't be instantly connected you
know so you can outrage mobs in london
because you know some some something
happened in the u.s like that's actually
a really weird phenomenon this hyper
connectivity i don't think that's going
away i don't think we can or necessarily
even should make that go away but i do
think like nope super powerful
multinational corporations shouldn't
have the power and the ability to swing
an election and i don't think you know
past a certain point past a certain
market cap or once you have 100 million
users on your platform or whatever i
think you're a common carrier and the
phone company can't you know
discriminate against us because we have
political views and so facebook
shouldn't be able to do it either to me
that's like the bare minimum that we
need to do
um you mean alex jones should be
entitled to a phone oh my gosh
yeah imagine and it's just getting worse
right banking i know like republican
political operatives in arizona wells
fargo has just shut out yeah they at
least had the grace to allow these
people to withdraw their money before
just closing the accounts but like
pretty soon like we are moving this way
social credit systems right like
we thought that uh helping china
industrialize would make them more like
us we thought it would turn them into a
liberal democracy no actually it's our
society's becoming remarkably a lot more
like china yeah a sort of oligarchy
controlled by a few people um obviously
our version looks different but i think
they're using big tech i think they're
using the university they're using
corporations ngos ford foundation all
this stuff it's it's really part of this
web that just kind of swims left do you
want to see is there money i think jd
vance said generally
he's the four dads yeah great yeah like
basically they're funding all these
things that are destroying america yeah
and let's take the money at least let's
tax them because they're not a real
non-profit there's huge non-profit
left-wing non-profit abuse in this
country yeah um all right so if if it's
not too late to do something about big
tech does it feel at least like there
was like this slow push
and then suddenly it became very rapid
where right now it feels like every day
we wake up and it's like there's some
other crazy thing happening whether it's
someone being banned or the credit card
stuff that you're talking about or
something related to speech or something
where it seems like and everything we
haven't we've barely talked about covid
where it's just like every day there's
some other crazy thing happening and it
feels like the algorithm's feeding it to
us like it doesn't feel organic to me
anymore when i wake up every morning and
there's just some you know and on
twitter experts say experts already
mentioned that
that something else is fueling like the
craziness here
hard to know i mean i agree with you
it's just getting crazier and crazier it
feels like a one-way ratchet how much is
intentional and manipulated and you know
designed for some effect versus just
this is the crazy consequence of the
world we live in it's very stagnant um
we have all you know eric weinstein
talks about embedded growth obligations
right like we have all these uh these
expectations that things just get better
and better in our society
but they actually don't like these
institutions broke a long time ago but
people i think are a little bit behind
the curve and realizing it and so i
think we're careening off the cliff here
like we're really close and i think
people feel that something is really
wrong
um
but but still the news cycle moves and
these momentary outrages and everybody
just pays attention we go from acute
crisis to acute crisis who even knows
what was in the news two weeks ago right
it's all just forgotten and i think the
short attention span juxtaposed with the
slow boil of sort of losing the country
losing these institutions
i think we're in a really bad spot is
there a country that you can kind of
point to that is sort of doing it in the
broad sense better like it seems like
every western nation is kind of
crumbling at the moment australia
they're attacking australia it's crazy
australia is crazy and like we don't see
that on our news here so if you say that
to some i mean i've brought this up with
family members you see what's going on
australia what's going on in australia
right like well actually they've got the
army out there hunting down people for
walking their dogs no it can't be then
you send them a video oh well that can't
possibly be it's just cherry picked yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but that you know australia canada we're
seeing western nations just nobody's
really doing it that well right now
nobody's doing it that well this is what
i realized it's like there's no place
else to go like the united states is the
leader and if we lose it here
it's got like i think western europe's
been gone for a long time it's just this
pessimistic managed decline um is it
eastern europe i mean is it countries
like poland sure
maybe but i mean
you know when tucker carlson goes to
hungary or whatever and the internet the
left loses their mind for a day right uh
i think maybe we have you know some
things to to learn or remember from
countries like that but they're also
very different countries right they're
small uh more homogeneous more sort of
poor and manageable it's like the us is
a very different
animal
um
and so i you know the us is not going to
become hungry and there are certain
things the ways in which we shouldn't so
it's like we should be the u.s we should
be the best version of america and a lot
of that uh is in the future and a lot of
that is in the past and again it's this
wisdom of knowing what's good about our
past like what do we as a people believe
in what's important what do we need to
carry forward and how should we navigate
the challenges of modern society and
these are questions that congress
literally does not debate like nobody
talks about this stuff in congress the
senate supposed to be the greatest
you know debate hall in the in the world
and it's not
it's it's just so it's not on the list
even that's not on the list but then
it's but to your point it's like what is
on the list right who is doing it well
and i think if the us falls it's like
there's really no global leader it's
like you could say china but obviously i
think that's a horrible dystopian
society that's not exactly there's this
weird love of china now from well from
the left because i think they're
enjoying the destruction of america in
essence sure but that's that's bad not
on that side yeah i think there's no
there's no good hope for for freedom as
we sort of know it and have cherished it
over the
you know decades in the american
experience
two centuries of the american experiment
like that there's nothing that says that
has to last forever this is what i think
people just take it for granted like oh
we live in america this is the best
country you know we're so exceptional
and it's like yeah i agree with all that
but at the same time if you take it for
granted and you let your institutions
decay and you let your government decay
you end up in this place where like
nothing works
and we live in this globalized world
where we're just
homogenizing and you know it doesn't
work and i think the left actually kind
of likes this in some weird way they get
the stratified society where we have the
thin elite at the top and you hollow out
the middle class and guess what the left
gets to be the elite right um that's
what i always say it's not but they
don't like the elites they just want
their people they just they are yeah
they are the elite right you go to the
same schools you think the same way
you run society you hollow out the
middle class and then you you have an
underclass right people who are
perpetually on the dole whether it's ubi
or just you know unlimited stimulus
checks or welfare as we know it um
that's a really bad model for society it
looks a lot more like brazil
than than the us or how the u.s is
supposed to look
and so i don't think it's um
i don't think it's over i think we can
still actually
sort of arrest that decline but it
starts by talking about it it starts by
waking people up
you know i tell people in these
republican
grassroots rooms that i go to like we've
been playing defense on the right for so
long that we're just out of space to
play defense our backs are against the
wall and so if we don't win in 2022 and
2024
it's over
and you'd think that's pessimistic and
demotivating but no actually it's like
optimistic because it means like
recognize the strategy you've been
employing has failed recognize the
stakes recognize the importance of what
we're fighting for and go on offense
like let's go fight and win because
otherwise they're going to pack the
supreme court they're going to add new
states to the union you know they're
going to federalize elections everything
will be woke there'll be a chinese style
social credit systems thought control
like in 10 years this country will look
like australia
you'll have the left-wing military like
you know hunting down people for
non-compliance like that can happen here
and that's my message for people it can
happen here
i was gonna ask you a little bit more
about arizona but you are a politician
now and you had a heart out for 50
minutes because you got to go fundraise
so you gave me a nice closer there
unless you want a bonus closer but
that's bonus closer you want a bonus
closer here we go uh bring it
look i think um
i'm just really excited to be running
for office it's not something i again as
discussed i didn't think 10 years ago
i'd be doing this i didn't think we'd
have the opportunity but president trump
came and gave us a new lease on life i
remind people who are like really sad
that he's not in office
that uh
okay that sucks now we have an
incompetent president we have a wide
open border inflation's going through
the roof that's bad but remember that
without president trump we'd be in year
five of a hillary clinton presidency and
i think that would be game over
and so consider the gift that even if
you thought it was chaotic even if you
didn't vote for him the second time you
know i disagree with you and that's
that's fine
but he gave us this new lease on life
and i think the dems and the left they
won't get it together like they don't
understand what's going on
but they're right if we can actually
just shed the paul ryanism if we can
update if we can rebuild a party that's
pro work in class pro american
pro family
we can actually still have a good future
like i know it's possible and so that's
why i get up every day and i'm excited
to run
i don't think it's naive i think we can
actually build a better future and so
that's what i'm trying to do
you give me two closers not bad two
closers not bad not bad thank you sir
thanks blake
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell